my mom okay
am I on on the other one yes okay all
right thank you
thanks to thanks to Amazon and thanks to
Jared and his team for hosting this
continuing to hustle the New York Armina
of all of these years so I'm going to
talk tonight about nonlinear modeling
our with generalized additive models and
talk about the EM GCV package this is
gonna be a little different than some of
the way I talk about this sometimes I
teach workshops sometimes on this but
what I want to do tonight is sort of
give you a tour of capabilities and the
kinds of things you can potentially do
with gams the types of data you can work
with the types of problems you can solve
because sometimes we tend to pick the
package or the model that solves the
problem that's immediately in front of
us does the package work with data
that's organized in the way that I'm
working does it work with this type of
output does it work with this type of
data size and we're not necessarily
always able instead of that immediate
moment to ask are we fitting the type of
model that's appropriate for the overall
system the overall problem that we're
dealing with and a lot of the reason for
that is we don't necessarily know deep
in these packages what are the
capabilities and so I have an argument
to make that generalized additive models
are very good solutions for a lot of
problems but in order to actually use
them you have to know how to tie them to
the different types of data and
different types of outputs and
visualizations and challenges that you
have so let me just start with a little
bit about myself I am a disease
ecologist my backgrounds
in modeling of infectious disease and
modeling of wildlife and forest dynamics
and I work at an organization called eco
health alliance and we work at the
intersection of conservation in human
health most of our work has to do with
how humans interact with organisms and
how that relates to how diseases spill
over from humans to wildlife and from
wildlife into people and it's a
worldwide organization or headquartered
here in New York have about a hundred
people overall and that ranges from
wildlife vets to software engineers data
scientists in between we have biologists
biologists a really great wild
interdisciplinary team trying to solve
problems and the reason this is relevant
to the work we're doing is we really
tend to work in trying to understand
complex systems not just to predict
what's going to happen although that's a
big part of it but trying to understand
what are really complex interactions
between wildlife population dynamics and
cell viral interactions and human
behaviors and all of that requires a
view on the models that we build that
they represent these sort of complex
nonlinear interactions in a way that we
can understand before I jump into the
models themselves I want to give thanks
to the beginning rather than the end so
we don't miss it there are three people
who I've been working with on gams for a
long time
Gavin Simpson Eric Peterson and David
Miller are all statistical ecologist of
various sorts and we have taught these
workshops together and when we give
talks on games we tend to exchange a lot
of material with each other so you'll be
seeing their work and themselves as
characters showing up a few times
through the presentation and we all owe
a great deal to Simon Wood who's a
statistician at the University of
Bristol I believe he is the author of
the MCZ PMG CV package and a great
statistician and behind a lot of the
important sort of applied game theory in
recent years so let
stop talking about why we might use a
generalized additive model before he
dive into the details of what they are
and the big reason is that we usually
face this interpretability complexity
trade-off in models that we fit so we
can fit models to data to do predictions
that are linear models they're
relatively easy to understand there's a
straight line that represents the
relationship between two variables that
passes through a cloud we're able to
make a simple graph of that we're able
to make some predictions off of that
we're able to interpret it and explain
it but linear models may not represent
our data well because our relationships
may not be linear at all and you may not
get good predictions out of something
like that you move to the other end of
the spectrum you have all sorts of black
box machine learning texts needs
techniques yeah your neural networks you
might be doing random forests you might
be doing booster to regression
regression trees all of these things
tend to be very good at prediction but
very difficult to interpret and very
difficult to get understanding what's
going on your system from fitting these
models so you might be able to do
classification but if you want to
understand how one variable relates to
your outcome you're not necessarily
going to do well especially when you're
looking globally sometimes you can look
at sort of very local regions within
your model and understand that but
understand global relationships they're
very tough gams provide a nice medium in
this you can fit relatively complex
relationships some complex interactions
and nonlinearities in your system but
you can generally visualize these models
you can generally see what the
relationship between different variables
are and why it gets the outcome so I
sort of think of the earth being these
three different components that you
might think about as reasons to use a
generalized additive model one is you
want to predict from a complex system
you have something that is complex and
not easily understandable at sort of a
linear level and you want to be able to
make predictions from it but you also
want to understand and make inferences
about those relationships about what
variable is important and how
moving and then oftentimes what you
actually want to do is you want to
control for the complex relationships to
ask for a very simple question so if
you're doing something like a bee
testing maybe all you really want to
know is that you know website version a
is you know getting more clicks than
website version B but then you have to
control for a lot of things that are
more complex like the seasonality or the
demographics of the people who are
approaching it or sort of all the time
of day or also it's a number of things
that aren't as simple as the simple a
bee comparison you're trying to do that
said gams are not bad a prediction at
all I don't you to think that you are
losing too much in this interpretability
thing so Kim Larsen a stitch fix as this
great post up comparing gams to a bunch
of other models for the purpose of
binary classification I think the
problem was here is from the insurance
industry that was there was a company
that was sending out mailers and they
were trying to look at the
characteristics of the people who got
those mailers and how likely they were
to become customers and so there's a
binary classification problem there are
60 odd variables maybe 10 to 20,000 data
points they're working with and she fit
a variety of different models as
predictors for this from random forests
support vector machines linear models
KNN based models and a bunch of
different versions of gams and gams
perform about as well or better than
most of these you get relatively good
predictive performance and the
predictive performance is that column of
the validation area under the receiver
operator or a curve which is those those
0.72 point values of the accuracy of
those models so let me give you just a
little bit of theory about what gams are
and how they work so gams generalized
additive models each of those words
means something the generalized compart
has to do with what type of data and
what type of outputs you're dealing with
when you have a straight linear model
you work with
normal normal distributions of data
Gaussian data a generalized linear model
can handle many different types of
outputs that are not normally
distributed so you got you can have
binary data zeros and ones choose and
falses you can have count data when
you're accounting having counters of
zero ones twos and threes or things that
are more exotic than that the additive
part means that there are multiple terms
in the model and they simply add
together to get your prediction the
difference between a general linear
model in general additive model is that
those individual terms are nonlinear and
then a model is a model that's not
entirely for she's too facetious
sometimes you have an algorithm that's
predictive that doesn't have a model
itself it's just a representation of the
data but it does it doesn't mean that
underlying we have some representation
the process we're talking about but the
key difference is looking at linear
versus nonlinear additive terms so if
you have some data that is nonlinear
like this and this is from my colleague
Gavin Simpsons work he does Paleo
climate so we have a time in history on
the bottom here and the measure there is
a proxy for temperature and one of the
lakes he works in so something is
clearly changing over time here and what
we could do is we could fit a linear
model to this which would be a
polynomial which is the red line that
goes down here it wouldn't be a very
good fit to the data it wouldn't capture
the complexity of this relationship in
this time series so another option is we
could fit a polynomial so we could fit a
quadratic term so X plus x squared or
something with X cubed or on to higher
and higher terms and they each might
capture more of the complexity of the
data but then first we have the problem
of trying to decide what's the
appropriate degree of polynomial to
capture this and then secondarily even
the polynomial type curves are limited
in the types of curves they can
represent for pretty much any polynomial
that's not explicitly modeling an
underlying say quadratic relationship
you're going to get strange residuals
and poor predictions
especially poor extrapolation so what
you want is to model a relationship that
can capture that data in a smooth way
get the main shapes and not overfit the
noise around it which would be what this
is which is a smoother or a spy a spline
which is sort of the essential building
block of a generalized additive model so
how are these splines constructed where
they're the way they work is they're
built up of lots of little functions so
each spline is the sum of lots of little
repeating functions that we have in the
data and each of those functions gets a
coefficient and then we sum those up
linearly in order to get your output
spline so here for fitting that data on
the Left I have example of the splines
before they get the coefficients before
they're fit to the curve and then
secondarily on there on the left right
we have once we put coefficients on each
of those they add up to that smoother so
each of these little functions is called
a basis function and the basis functions
add together to get a spline now there
are lots of different types of basis
functions we'll go to and one of the
nice things about them
is it can be tailored to the type of
problem that you have and they don't
have to be one dimensional so basis
functions can represent higher order
relationships in two or three or more
dimensions so you can model a surface or
the relationship between two variables
and outcome with the sum of a bunch of
two-dimensional basis functions to
create a two-dimensional spline so this
is an example of that on the bottom
right there's a fitted surface that we
might use to model data and it is made
up of weighted sums of all of the other
two-dimensional three-dimensional
surfaces of two dimension of two
variables that are there so you multiply
each of those relationships by the
little coefficient by them you get that
thing on the bottom right and that's how
we assemble this complex relationship
that
let's us model a complex system now
these splines have to be the appropriate
level of wiggliness right they have to
fit our data but not our noise and so so
the fundamental problem in fitting agam
is optimizing that degree of wiggliness
of your spline or your smoother and so
you have a trade-off to make in that so
there's a degree of fit which usually is
a measure of the likelihood of the model
which I have on the left of this term
here and then on the right there's a
measure of wiggliness W which is
essentially just how much a function
oscillates and balancing the two is this
smoothing parameter here which we call
lambda and so when one is fitting a
model you're basically running an
optimizer to pick the right lambda to
trade-off between fitting your data and
avoiding fitting your noise so dealing
with lambda is sort of the core of what
M GCV does and you want to make sure you
have it right which is all I want to do
miss the big reveal where do we switch
not just do this
all right there we go so if lambda is
correct you'll model a relationship well
so in these three graphs we have a real
process in blue and a fitted model
in black with noisy data around it in
the circles so on the Left we're fitting
our relationship well because we have
picked to correct lambda
but if our lambda is too small near zero
you're going to over fit data because
you're going to have too many bases and
too much wiggliness in your function or
if your lambdas too large you're going
to have too simple a function to
represent the complexity of your
relationship so really the core problem
to solve is what is this smoothing
parameter and how do we balance
overfitting versus capturing the
complexity in our relationship and
there's a lot to talk about how these
smoothing models work but we're gonna
skip that tonight because I want to talk
about capabilities so we're gonna cost
it out and remind you that this is what
M GCV does for you and is sort of the
core contribution to the package and I
can talk a great deal about it later on
over beers or or otherwise but I want to
move to how we actually fit these things
in our on a practical basis so let's get
to a little bit of the syntax of how we
build these models in our so fitting the
gamin our works a lot like fitting a
linear model or fitting a generalized
linear model if you fit a linear model
in our it's a function you call LM you
define a formula of your model so your
outcome Y is a linear function of
variables X 1 and X 2 and those X 1 and
X 2 are in your data frame you pass that
function your data the difference with a
generalized linear model is in addition
to your formula and your data you are
giving a distribution family to say what
type of data you're working with so you
might instead of normal data say we're
working with binomial data or count data
with a Poisson family or something like
that
M GCV is similar so if you load them GCV
library you first if I and you
the GAM function and you define a model
formula so the model formula is similar
to a linear or a generalized linear
model you have an outcome your Tilda you
can have a linear component to that
model as we have an x1 or we wrap the
variable in this s function the smoother
which will produce this nonlinear
relationship between X 2 and the output
once again we pass the data frame of
those inputs the data we can give the
family in this case we're saying
Gaussian so a normalized output and then
finally there's this component method
equals a Remmel which stands for
relative maximum likelihood method tells
M GCV what method it should use to pick
lambda that smoothing parameter again we
could go a lot into it but pretty much
unless you have very good reasons you
should use your ml as the method it's
not the default but the package author
or all the theorists would say this is
the right way to do it these days the
default is just there essentially for
backwards compatibility which is this
GBP method if we dive into the formula
for the GAM model itself a little bit we
see there's more components you can have
so the GAM formula first can have a
linear term if you want something linear
in there you can have it which is just
putting that x1 value up without
anything wrapped around it then the
smoother function which you wrap your
other variable in starts with the
variable itself and then it has a number
of other arguments the BS argument is
the basis that tells you what type of
spline urse we want to build what types
of functions to build it up from the
default is what's called a thin plate
spline which is a very good option for a
lot of cases you have a K value which is
the number of basis functions you're
actually going to include so you
actually have a lot of leeway with K
because the smoothing parameter takes
care of how complex your functions going
to be so K just has to be large enough
to represent what might be the
complexity in the
the smoothing function will smooth it
down if it's too much so you just don't
need it you don't don't it to be too low
because then you can't represent complex
data and the own T's so high as to
overload your machine computationally
but within that the great thing about mg
CV is it tastes care of it for you and
then there's a bunch of other options
which tend to be dependent on what type
of basis you're using and we'll get into
those when you do those so you fit a
model you get you can get an individual
you can get a spline which is a
relationship like this but maybe you
want to have a complex multi-dimensional
interacting relationship between
multiple variables two or more so there
are a number of different ways you can
do that so you might have multiple
splines that add up so that's the first
line here just outcome is the sum
additively of spline of x1 and spline of
x2 but you can make an interacting term
which is two-dimensional like that
surface I showed you of just saying
let's have the output be a function of
the spline of x1 and x2 together and
that gives you a two-dimensional
relationship that two-dimensional
relationship assumes that both x1 and x2
should be equally Wiggly so you have a
surface that's equally Wiggly in both
dimensions you can relax that as well
with this alternate formulation called
with te which is what's called a tensor
spline which does the same thing but
uses two different lambdas so x1 x2
might make sense if you're looking at
two dimensions in space but if you're
doing space and times which are clearly
operating on different scales you might
use something like a tensor and one of
the neat things is you can pull apart
the relationship and have what is the
part that is just X 1 what is the part
that is just X 2 and what is the part of
the interaction just like in a linear
model you might have two linear terms in
interaction and you do that by having a
tensor of X 1 a tensor of X 2 and then a
tensor interaction of the two and then
you
manage those variables and those
interactions independently so what does
this actually look like so I tell you
these two-dimensional gams are very good
for representing things in space so one
example of that is this work by David by
David Miller David is a statistical
ecologist who works in marine systems
most of what he does has to do with
finding and counting whales and dolphins
so this is data he's worked with in the
trying to model populations of dolphins
in the Gulf so we have a bunch of data
from NOAA trawl surveys where they go
out and watch for marine mammals and so
as they do that it each dot along this
path that they have they look out and
observe for dolphins and see the number
that they count but we want to model
that as a full 2d surface so we create a
gam where the density of dolphins D is a
spatial function so an S of x and y X&Y
being the coordinates on the map okay
and also a function of depth so now we
have an additive model that says these
are the two components that we think are
important location and depth and
figuring out where these dolphins are
we're going to give it the data of
dolphin observations and then we can
make a prediction which is this surface
which is brighter where we have a higher
predicted density of the animals and
darker where it's not so that's the this
spatial approach is a really good way of
using gams because that term s of X and
y can really soak up a lot of the
unobserved variation beyond your other
variables that might be explanatory like
depth
that uses sort of the standard basis
function I just that the thin plate
spline that TP was the defaults there
are a lot of different basis functions
for different types of things you would
like to model so if we're continuing to
make models of spatial data you're doing
you know you're mapping City you're
mapping city travel you're looking to
for where voters are right there are a
number of specialized smoothes for
problems you might encounter one of them
are these soap film smooth maybe you're
modeling a system where the topology is
somewhat complex so the example we might
have here and my work is if you're
looking at a lake in a lake is a complex
shape then you should have you know
what's here in the lake does not relate
to here in the lake even though it's
close sort of on an absolute basis
there's this peninsula blocking it off
okay so if we just say be s equals s oh
and say we want a soap film smoother it
will understand that we have a shape we
want to work with and we want to and we
pass in a list a simple polygon and it
will understand model the spatial data
within this polygon and don't cross the
boundaries so that solves one type of
spatial problem another spatial problem
that you might have is you're working at
a very large scale you're doing
something global and so it matters that
things can go around the world one way
or around the world the other way and it
matters the projection of data onto a
sphere it's not as simple X&Y
so there's another spatial basis type
for another type of smooth called a
spline on a sphere and all we have to do
to get that is pass a basis of SOS and
then we can just pass latitude and
longitude coordinates model a system
where we're looking at spatial variation
along a sphere on earth or any other
planet you might be modeling so those
are good basis functions for space
there's also a whole series of ones that
are good for a time or combine systems
so I tend to use a lot what's called
Gaussian process smooth has anyone
worked with Gaussian processes in other
contexts very few okay so a Gaussian
process is essentially a a very good way
of representing Auto correlated data so
a lot of times when you have time series
the if you were to fit a normal spline
or a linear model to something in time
you would have autocorrelation amongst
your residuals you wouldn't get good
estimates of your errors it wouldn't
account for the fact that your
observations aren't independent each one
is reliant on the next and that's
essentially the type of variation that
Gaussian processes capture so in some of
the work where I do we are actually
sampling bats for viruses against
antibodies and we follow a cohort over a
period of time to see how diseases are
cycling in these animals and so we
measure their blood for how the for
whether they've been exposed to a
disease and we can see how the disease
cycles in the population we want to
model that so we can predict in time how
that'll work so this is a graph of that
the dots are showing at individual
points where we're sampling how
prevalent antibodies against the virus
are we fit a spline in time and I use
that Gaussian process basis to create
that spline and that takes care of that
time autocorrelation problem for us if
you're doing something in time like if
you're doing if you have something with
website clicks over time sales over time
when customer acquisition happens when
different directions happen you probably
have something that has to do with a
seasonal component or a weekly component
where things are always different on the
weekend or a monthly component because
things vary over the course of the month
and people act differently right before
they've paid their bills and right after
they've paid their bills you probably
have something that cycles in time and
you often want to understand what's the
cyclic component versus what's the
long-term trend and that's a natural fit
for a additive model because those are
two components you can add together that
themselves are nonlinear
so for another version of this work
where we were looking at a series of
viruses within our bat population we
wanted to know what the seasonal
component was was there a season that
was more prevalent and how did that
compare to the changes over a longer
period of time so for that I fit a game
that has that same Gaussian process
which helps take care of the
autocorrelation and do the long term
work and then add another another smooth
with a basis that's CC which is what's
called a cubic cycle spline and then
that type of spline which is the ones
represented in the graphs on the top is
flexible but the beginning and the end
is always the same so it can represent a
cyclic component like your weekly or
monthly or seasonal or annual things
then there are smooths that are not
purely smooth so this is something that
David David Miller and said we were
having a conversation about this which
is that ultimately what a smooth is is
basically and assembling a relationship
out of smaller parts and then penalizing
its complexity some way to deal with
noise and in a broad sense you can
represent any type of relationship this
way which means they don't necessarily
have to be sort of continuous splines
you can have discrete or other types of
relationships represented in the same
way smooth are and that lets you fit a
broader class of relationships as well
so the simplest version of these is
discrete random effects you might just
have a bunch of different categories you
want to model so each you know you can
have some things like age classes or
maybe there's a you know a difference
between you know how much people like a
different color of a product which are a
different discrete category and you want
to model those different levels as part
or as a whole of a as a whole of a gam
and you can just do that as a random
effect this would be a random effect in
your other generalized linear as mixed
models that you might fit with the LME
for package or the NL mu package
and but all it is essentially is that we
have these smaller components that we
penalize so that they don't differ too
much from an overall component and for a
gam you just use the re smoother to
represent this and pass X as a factor so
you can model discrete levels and one of
the neat things you can do is we had
continuous interactions and we have
these discrete levels you can actually
have interactions between a discrete
level or random effects and a continuous
smooth so let's say you have patient
progression over a time there's some
overall effective say have someone's
health or response or some other
relationship is changing over time and
then there are differences between the
individual patients for that as well you
could model that using what's called a
factor smooth interaction and there are
two ways of specifying this in mg CV
they're sort of a shortcut which is the
factor smooth so the first line here we
model an output as a function of an X
that's a continuous variable and an X
that's a factor variable so continuous
might be time the factor might be which
patient and the basis we use is factor
smooth and that's just a shortcut for a
tensor smooth in which one basis is some
sort of continuous version and one basis
is this random effect now one of the
things you can do with this is you can
pull pull out an overall effect and then
look at how different groups or
different individuals deviate from that
so this once again looking at our bat
virus circulation work we had a series
of different bats when measured when
they were born and then how things
progressed with them over time and we
were interested in how that overall
effect worked in a wild and how we could
predict predict it but then how the in
the different groups of bats actually
varied from that and so this case we do
an additive model where we have
an overall effect and an interactive
effect so we have a gam we have an
outcome in this case it's binomial
though I left it off the formula I use
one smooth to represent the central
effect so the continuous variable in
time using that Gaussian process so
we're using that we're dealing with
autocorrelation and then we have another
effect that's the interaction of that
process the factor of which group of
animals were looking at and the basis is
the combination of Gaussian process and
a random effect and so you're able to
separate those components out and in the
graph we have sort of the overall
pattern of everything in these thick
lines but we can see the individual
deviances and capture the variation
there one of their really interesting
sort of spline like things that's out
there is something called Markov random
fields these are really good for
modeling when you have spatial area data
so spatial area data is just things like
countries and states and counties or
land use or parcels where you have areas
in space that are adjacent to each other
but them to sell themselves are discrete
units we don't have sort of continuous
spatial variation and they're kind of
like random effects and kind of like
smoothes and the idea of a Markov random
field is that something in space that's
a unit like that has its own value but
it probably correlated with the values
of things adjacent to it right so you're
not necessarily just saying oh this is
its own value and it's probably some
deviation from an overall mean but
something in County County X is most
likely to be correlated to County Y that
is next to it and so that still fits
into this overall here are the
components and here's the penalisation
framework where we say it has its own
component as its own effect we penalize
it to make it more like the things next
to it and we can just do that with a
smooth whose basis is the Markov random
field and in this case you pass a list
which is just a
a list of neighborhood so that can just
take a list of polygons or a list in
which there's a vector which shows what
are the neighbors of each individual
component so it actually works for
anything you can represent as a network
or a graph so another field in which
this works is when we do phylogenetics
looking at the relationships and
ancestry is a different species in our
work you know we can look at the
neighbors as things that share a nearest
ancestor has organisms that are similar
to each other whereas ones that are sort
of further along the tree are further
away this example here is county level
educational attainment it comes from
Gavin Simpsons blog which I'll have the
link for later and it sort of shows how
we have variation but also spatial
correlation amongst counties in terms of
how many people attain a house a high
school degree and that's what's able to
be modeled in this Markov random field
way finally there's something called an
adaptive smooth so most models I
described have a single penalizing
component which gives you an overall
wiggliness of your curve but sometimes
you have the challenge where the
relationship is different along
different parts of the range so on the
Left we have a traditional smooth so we
have a part of our relationship the
underlying real relationship is in a red
the model is in black with the
confidence intervals in gray it's
totally flat for some part and then gets
wild later on and the model has trouble
capturing the fact that something is
totally flat on one side and Wiggly on
and Wiggly on the other because it has a
single sort of overall wiggliness
defining it so you can have the Wiggly
mustiness itself change as a curve over
time and that can capture that kind of
effect though this type of spline is
just a little more data hungry because
it has to fit these pieces piecewise and
have enough information to do the
penalisation along the way
so you have a whole wide set of smoothes
and the smoothes capture different types
of relationships but you also have a
whole bunch of different types of data
and types of outcomes you might be
modeling so you might say okay something
is going to be nonlinear related to Y
but my outcome are you know our ratings
or count data or types or or choose or
false or things that are much more
exotic and those are things that are
implemented in lots of packages
throughout our so your general
linearized model will capture a certain
set of distributions but you might have
a certain package for a beta
distribution whose are modeling
probabilities or you have a special
package for the type of sensor data that
you're looking at as well one of the
neat things about I'm GCV is just the
sheer number of probability distribution
outcomes that have been built into the
package so you can capture a lot of
those different types of things without
wandering off or something specialized
to the problem so one example of that is
dealing with data that has a lot of
outliers in it maybe the data you have
has very fat tails it doesn't fit with a
normal distribution because you have a
lot of extreme values in it so you would
want to fit a model in which your
outcome distribution is fat-tailed if
you fit a normal distribution it
wouldn't capture right the GAM i'm GCV
includes a student's t distribution and
the student's t-distribution can adjust
the fatness of the tails from being like
a normal distribution to being much
broader and if you fit data that has a
lot of outliers like this example here
if you would use a normal distribution
on the Left those outliers would really
mess with the relationship the red gamm
wouldn't capture what's the black
overall true relationship with all those
outliers but if you use a student's
t-distribution with those fat tails you
can capture it much better you might
have count data there's standard count
there's a bunch of standard
distributions you might use for count
data
and generalized linear models as a
Poisson distribution which is for
account data that's sort of evenly
distributed throughout throughout the
individual the individuals you're
looking at if you have over dispersed
data you might use something called you
might use the negative binomial
distribution which is also common in
general linear models but there's a
series of others that could be more
exotic so for instance M GCV has
implemented the tweeny distribution
which is very good when you are looking
at counting things that are clustered in
groups and so you're missing those
groups sometimes and you're hitting
those groups sometimes and that's
actually exactly what we use in this
dolfyn data where we're modeling in
space so dolphins don't just like aren't
just like evenly distributed through the
sea because they're social and they come
together in pods and you go out and you
watch for them you're not going to sort
of catch get them evenly you're going to
run into groups of them and get big
numbers and small numbers and that can't
be represented with a process on or even
a negative binomial very well but a
tweety distribution captures that type
of problem very well maybe you have an
outcome that's not a sort of a measure
number but you have an ordered
categorical data so ordered categorical
data could be ratings you have something
on your website people are rating one
two three four stars
you have survey data in which people are
rating things on a scale of one to five
so it's numerical but and there's an
order to it but things aren't
necessarily continuous in that range
they're not necessarily evenly spaced
giimpse can handle that very well
there's a set up for order categorical
data where essentially you fit a spline
or a smooth and the GAM fits just
thresholds along that to determine where
something transitions from one group to
another
so then capture the fact that people are
like really like normal when they're
going to one two four but like really
hesitancy to rate a five so you can't
just like think of things as linear you
know it's something more calm
flex that causes them to jump from level
to level so this is an example in which
we're looking at what makes it more or
less likely that something is
categorized in these different
conservation categories by the
International Conservation Union in
terms of different species and so we
look at how animals size affects that
and as size changes it hits threat you
know the relationship on average its
thresholds that move up between these
different categories and all you have to
do to do that is have your outcome being
ordered factor in R and give the family
as okat to capture this there's a lot
more in this you might be categorizing
you might have non ordered categories
that might be exclusive or not so you're
predicting tags on a tags on a document
or something like that or you might have
something with that outcomes are
multiple you're trying to predict height
and weight you know they're correlated
they're both outcomes of the same
process both of those things that are
families for you can do the former as a
multinomial the latter as a multivariate
normal both of these are in mg CV you
just pass a list of formulas that can be
the same formulas for the outcomes or
different formulas so you can say but we
have a common process but the variables
are a little different for the different
type of outcomes we're looking at or the
same things are predicting the same
types of outcome so in the first one the
first one is the same we say variable x1
and x2 both help us determine the
category and we have two different
categories because we say K equals 2 in
our family but in the bottom case you
might say well we have two different
variables that are potential outputs
the first one is predicted by x1 and x2
the second one is predicted by x1 and x3
so they share some information but not
all I probably covered about two thirds
of what's there but I'm not going to go
through all of the other distributions
but the big message I want to say is
that if you're using a gamete very
likely can solve problem depends
if you're if you have a lot if you have
a particular distribution of the outcome
of data mg CV has outcomes for survival
data it has if you have to model the
variation and not just the mean of your
data if there's sensor data there's a
button and then there's a series of
others and Simon keeps adding more of
these as we go so you rarely have to
leave the world with this package to get
the outcome you want there was beta
proportional stuff and a bunch others so
that covers on one hand the types of
relationships in our splines its handles
the types of outcomes but then there's a
bunch of other problems you might have
in that you're trying to solve and
there's that re are sort of sort of main
sort of predict based on your main
predictive goals and M GCV is able to
solve a number of these so one problem
is variable selection you have a model
you're not interested in just prediction
you want to select what are the most
important variables there so you can
discard the rest so you can have
something parsimonious something that is
easier to explain something that is
easier to collect the data for something
that will run quickly so M GCV has this
great argument select equals true to add
to the end of your your model to do
variable selection and what select
equals true will do is add in addition
to a penalty on how Wiggly the
relationship should be it allowed a
penalty on its overall slope as well
which is the same as doing something
like Ridge regression or a lasso which
essentially penalize --is too much of
influence of the relationship unless
there's an updated support it and so if
I fit a model that has six smooths for
six different variables but three of
them are spurious
but it will just the limit those those
variables altogether and leave them as
nothing but zero coefficients on the
model so we have the individual splines
that are fit for each of these up here
the three on the top X 1 X 2 X 3
actually means something the ones in the
bottom
I just completely factored it out and so
you can run your model and say we don't
have to use these at all
it doesn't they're they're not
significant they're not predictive
they're penalized down gams can be
relatively computationally intensive but
it's something that Simon has actually
worked a lot on which is creating this
alternative function called BAM within
gam which is sort of like the Big Data
version of gam it basically you're able
to do a lot of we were able to do with
gam already but it uses a set of
approximations and is able to do sort of
a more memory efficient and paralyze
Abul approach so you can scale from you
know what you might have in a regular
game with thousands of data points to
sort of the tens and hundreds of
thousands or lots more interactions with
something called with BAM so I just have
two examples here running gam and bam
and bam is about ten times faster on
this sort of example of 10,000 data
points or so but the bigger thing about
it is it's much more memory efficient so
you'll probably when you have a big
model with lots of interactions you can
easily overload the memory of a machine
Bam is able to do things piecewise in
such a way to avoid this you can handle
much larger problems and it has almost
everything in it that gam can do some of
the weirder output distributions is not
quite capable of handing me handling yet
but it has more every time and probably
eventually will just replace the basic
gam function maybe this is what I'm
describing doesn't even adequately
capture the relationships that you've
had you have something that has complex
nested hierarchical effects and you're
someone who uses multi-level nested
models like you might have in NLM E or
LM e for now there's these extended
components that generalized additive
mixed model and the updated version of
generalize data in mixed model for which
is a separate package but in a partner
10mg CV and it basically combines the
LME for package with M GCV and lets you
have go to these complex or random
effect
model and so this random if this bold
part random effects lets you have a sort
of a nested hierarchical structure for
your slopes and your intercepts and
combine that with the smooth functions
and again or maybe you're a Bayesian
your iconoclast in a bit of a masochist
and you know you want to make sure that
you have informative priors and you are
modeling something that has full
distributions of the the posteriors and
be able to draw from that and that's
something that is sort of their rapidly
developing more options for a to Simon
developed this function called jagan
which will generate jagz code Jag's as a
Bayesian sampler just another Gibbs
sampler you run jag am on your gam and
it just generates the code you can run
another program if you're if you stand
if you're fan of Andrew Gelman is a lot
of us are are here and his work the Stan
team in the R Stan arm package has
developed a function that basically
clones your M GCV model based on what's
in gam for and it runs an in Stan and
returns it and so I sort of have an
example here of modeling time series
data with that where you can draw from
the posterior or that Bayesian model and
generate lots of different posterior
splines and then if you're like really
at the experimental cutting edge of
Bayesian modeling there's this new
package called Greta which is Bayesian
model modeling built on top of tensor
flow it's just starting out david miller
has implemented an experimental thing
where we can take with the output of jag
am turning into Greta and so then you
can run your Bayesian models in tensor
flow and use GPUs and get all of this
associating speed up and connect with
other tools associated there
so I've given you a whole lot in this in
terms of spline types output types other
features this is was certainly not an
introduction of how to so much as sort
of this you know merry-go-round of
possibilities of how you can model
things with GAM so let me just give you
a little bit of resources we might you
might go to to do more first of all is
within the mg CV package itself Simon
has a tendency to like write half of a
chapter of his book and make it a help
file and stick it in the package before
he updates the version of his book so if
you go into the help of mg CV you'll see
beyond these very helpful functions
function documentation there's a bunch
of things like these smooth terms
missing data gem selection which are
like short essays on how to deal with
certain problems so they're not
vignettes which is where you would
expect to see that in the package there
help file so dig into that when you get
when you're doing that he also has a
book that's very good it's relatively
mathematical but it starts at a very
basic level so it's a very good step
thing from linear models to generalize
linear models to generalize additive
models so it's sort of heavy in math
notation but it presumes very little
from the beginning so that's a great
resource secondarily Gavin Simpson has
this spectacular blog of his from the
bottom of the heap about sixty percent
when we blogs about is experimenting
with gams stuff and so he'll always post
code and data
he'll try things out he has a recent
thing on using Markov random fields and
how to do it that's where that map of
educational attainment come from he will
try he will be trying things out
constantly we're constantly debating
about approaches to that he's fantastic
he's also I have to had to do this
because he's the kind of guy that you
can go into doing your work for it for
you if you do something correctly so
this someone posted this on Stack
Overflow the spatial thing and he wrote
down here this has had something I'd
like to do all of this but it's kind of
hopelessly complex which is just like a
way of like goading him to like putting
a really you know put
together a really complex model
assembling the code for the whole thing
giving you a whole like is his model was
fitting he says one set of outputs as an
example of these relationships
here's another like a different
alternative formulation predicting
across the whole data set
he made this animation I think you know
this is while the Markov random fields
were fitting I think and so you know I
just need to give this guy a shout out
because how supportive is and how useful
he is for asking questions about that
I call this trolling driven data science
with Gavin asked if asked if a gam can
if say it said the game probably can't
do it and he'll show you a way that can
that said so
Gavin David Eric and I we've taught a
workshop every year for the Ecological
Society of America which probably most
of you are not going to but we put all
those course materials online there on
my there on my github account we have
slides which are very different than the
slides I showed here they show a lot
more code a lot more outputs a lot more
how to's as well as a series of
exercises that are both created by us by
our data and stuff drawn from Simon
woods book so that'll be available
finally hopefully sometime in spring
there will be a data camp course that
I'm currently laid on getting some stuff
to put together for but sometime in the
spring or so we will have a data camp
course on essentially how to fit these
models how to check these models how to
visualize these models and how to
predict for them so hopefully between
those things and between my sales pitch
about the Wonderland of different
approaches that mgcp gives you you might
be able to do something with gams that's
useful for you and that's it thank you
very much
[Applause]
I don't know how I don't know how late I
went so questions alright
all right great
yeah so and go to gams have a predict
function s/3 s/3 method just like you
have for linear models and generalized
linear models you know it's like the
like the others it's predict gam it'll
give you the predictions for your model
as it is there's you go to the help for
particular for that game there's a lot
of different options because you can say
predict for the individual smooth you
know you can predict with or without the
intercepts you can create sort of you
can export using the predict function
matrix which lets you do all the
calculations with a simple sort of
linear function so you can export that
to a different language or a different
framework so you can use a game that you
fit in our to you know run something in
JavaScript because you have the
prediction matrix from it but it's this
sort of same standard predict framework
a lot of the other standard frameworks
rapid so the Broom package which says
tidying of coefficients and predictions
it's tidy and augment functions all work
on gam there is a gam wrapper in the
carrot package for prediction so you can
put a gem model into carrot and compare
it against other predictive models you
might build and has most of the standard
infrastructure that you see around
predictive and inference models and are
yes
I'm not sure about so I mean there's
there it's an approximation like my
guess is that for most cases that those
approximations are not going to make a
difference if you have noisy data so it
actually it discretize is some of your
continuous data to simplify some of the
calculations essentially and then again
you might have some of the you know
basically up until the last version of
Mg cv a whole lot of the distributions
were not available now a lot more of
them are so it's becoming a smaller and
smaller set of reasons to avoid it
they hope that the combination of these
days
right so I mean and so this is a little
bit about we're sort of the philosophy
of the GLM are the GAM can butt up
against something like the the random
forest because you have to you have to
like you have to make the decision
yourself right as to what you want to
represent and what degree of complexity
you want to represent in my experience
actually having interaction terms of
more than three like starts to get out
of hand you know because you're the
number of you know the number of terms
in the model is you know increasing
exponentially as you do that and so when
you start having when you start having a
smooth that smooth of ABCDE and F both
the optimizers don't do particularly
well in finding the right coefficients
and then from my perspective more
importantly that is at least as
difficult to interpret as anything else
I mean once you start having that degree
of interactions you're very unlikely to
be able to directly interpret what's
happening you had you can't visualize
beyond to sort of the 3d spline right in
which case it might make more sense to
do something like a random forest for
that degree of combination that said we
have plenty of games that have 40
variables in them they're just not
necessarily interacting variables so the
interactions tend to be two or three
different components that were
interested in that and we think are
important and then everything else is
additive so individual not more linear
terms but more one or two dimensional
splines and that's where it really gets
to what your particular system is that
you're modeling and what you're
interested in and what's optimal doing
No one or two or three
yeah
charges
yeah no I mean so you know gam like the
bass gam you know is something it's
tends to work in the thousands of tens
of thousands you know BAM is something
that I mean it depends on what you're
you know what you know BAM you can start
using like you have multiple threads and
you can do more things than there's a
lot more variation but I haven't worked
with BAM with more than hundreds of
thousands of rows that said so one of
the things is that there's this there's
this rule of there's a of it's proved
it's more than a rule of thumb but so
the complexity of spline sort of
increases at it's a so rule tomorrow a
1/5 power of them number of data the
amount of data that you have okay so the
more data you have at a certain point
has very little influence on the
complexity of the spline that you fit
essentially so there's sort of a plateau
of the amount of data you need probably
you're not going to get a big difference
between a model that randomly subsets
you know you know a hundred thousand out
of your 10 million points then uses all
10 million points
yeah so one thing I mean and bam does a
little better and game doesn't do it
great sort of computationally it doesn't
do a whole lot taking advantage of the
sparsity right so like the matrices that
make up these smoothes are sparse
matrices but very little in game
actually takes advantage of that
computationally and that's the reason
that you have these challenges BAM
improves on it but like but in a partial
sort of piecewise way as opposed to like
moving to an entire sparse structure
well no so what happens is within within
the game we don't Gama's with this
select equals true ops argument within
within gamma when we add this it's doing
something that is almost exactly
equivalent to a lasso and of itself
right so the central thing that gamma is
doing is it's penalizing the overall
wiggliness of these functions your lasso
actually penalize --is the overall slope
right so it select equals true as it
says penalize both atom 1 penalty for
wiggliness and one penalty for slope and
so you're essentially getting the lasso
effect here by adding select equals true
and so you're not you don't have to do
is you're not doing a separate model
here by doing that and it'll also do
that if you have linear terms if some
things are smooth and some things are
just individual terms you can have that
select penalize those linear terms as
well
we'll talk more I'll be there
yeah yes
yeah it does because you have an ordered
categories so just simply you know the
first one here is your reference right
and then you have the threshold that's
which the thresholds and switch so
you're estimating four five four four
categories three thresholds in addition
to the smooth itself right and so you
have like one of them is one of them is
the base and then what is the change
going by this threshold initials in this
threshold but you do keep that reference
category much like when you have a fixed
effect model one thing is the intercept
and the rest are the the fixed effects
it's very so this is so it's very this
is very similar to something like
proportional odds model but of a portion
Allods model is still linear so what
might what you might say that like the
things that are affecting this outcome
right along this continuous scale are
not constant because you know it makes a
big difference as you move you know
between the lion and the elephant size
relative to moving between the like cat
and the lion size and so it's the
non-linearity that's at the point and
you can have that non-linearity in as
many terms as you want to more
I mean the overall package so I mean
mgcp has been in ours core for about 10
years now Simon does it Simon as a
statistician does a great deal of rigor
rigor tests during both sort of like
theoretically and empirically so things
like you know you look at the you know
things like the Select equal like the
selection stuff he has a series of
papers empirically on how well that
penalisation works versus other sort of
like approaches like doing AIC
comparison against all the different
models with all the different types of
variables and how their performance how
their performances in terms of the you
know like rigor of the code you know
there's definitely a like pretty good
testing coverage of it he's relatively
old-school em GCV is not on github it
doesn't use continuous integration as
far as I know the most recent version is
always exists only on his computer until
it's released through our Forge and then
and then our cran you know I think it's
as reliable as base are you know he's a
he's a narc he's a narc or a member his
statistical work is you know the
statistical work is is very good these
aren't particularly you know this field
is not a particularly exotic set of
models ultimately it goes down to these
are linear combinations it's not like
some of some of the machine learning
work is like purely empirical right we
don't know why some of these why some of
the machine learning neural network
stuff works so it's much more important
that you had the type of rigor but then
ultimately what you have to do is you
have to you know test your models when
you fit them and look at the outputs and
look at how they're working on your your
test data and your validate and your
validating holdout you certainly can get
into cases where the optimizers fail
right like if you have too many too many
coefficients if you set your K values
too high you can have something hit some
local minima that's not where the model
should be
usually the Diagnostics will tell you
that but it's the thing you have to
check
in charge
right
you can run it without actually
filter out your variables before
that would know the select that's it
wouldn't work that way
so what happens so like the central
machinery of what's happening is gamma
is iterating trying to find this correct
smoothing value this penalty right so
it's doing so it's doing that it's
measuring the likelihood of the the
model at a given smoothing penalty it's
adjusting coefficients and smooth and
the smoothing penalty to get it to get
it right the the Select equals true just
adds more to that machinery by saying
we're gonna have another penalty not
just on how Wiggly the functions are but
on how steep their slopes are and so the
using the Select equals true is pretty
integral like has to happen while the
model is being fit essentially so if
you're trying to eliminate potential
variables you might fit you know that
would be probably the place where you
want to do something diagnostic early on
and like do you know do your pairs plots
to look at relationships essentially see
which ones have no correlations one
thing that is in the the package is a
thing called concavity which is
basically a nonlinear measure similar to
collinearity and that's one thing you
might do is like looking at us looking
at small at subsets of variables of how
come conqueror of a shish they are to
see if like they have some degree of
relationship that you're interested in
fitting and exploring more it's also an
important thing for checking your models
because just like only linearity
concavity can screw up your estimations
and your confidence intervals and